a pregame flyover has been a tradition
for 51 of the last 52 Super Bowls for
Super Bowl 53 the NFL turned to the
Thunderbirds Dana Jacobson was allowed
to fly with the air force demonstration
team and learn how it prepares for this
high-profile assignment she's inside the
CBS Sports Super Bowl game production
truck at mercedes-benz Stadium in
Atlanta Dana good morning good morning
to you now when Gladys Knight is
finishing the national anthem on Sunday
the Thunderbirds will be roaring over
mercedes-benz stadium along with the
people inside about a hundred million
people could be watching worldwide on
their televisions now that key broadcast
moment will be brought to you from the
people here in this truck and while it
will only be on your screens for just a
few seconds many making it just right
getting it perfect well that has been
months in the making and it started
about two thousand miles away
[Music]
the US air force thunderbirds are a
high-speed death-defying squadron of
fighter pilots steering f16 jets through
all inducing maneuvers often mere feet
from one another they Wow crowds air
shows and sporting events around the
world a little extra bounce in the step
when you know you're doing the super
definitely a little bit more excitement
could be our biggest event of the year
Lieutenant Colonel Erik corny also known
as Thunderbirds 7 is the operations
officer charged with planning Sunday's
flyover the trickiest part of doing a
Super Bowl flyover is what the trickiest
part is getting the timing just right
the first thing to remember is we're
going 400 miles an hour so we can't just
stop and hover and the other tricky
thing is that we have committed to the
flyover we have started flying in about
a minute prior to the national anthem
even starting
in addition to training in the skies
above Nellis Air Force Base in Nevada
the pilots work in simulators their
screens filled with the Atlanta
cityscape but nothing beats the real
thing a practice fly over soaring above
mercedes-benz stadium there we go and we
got to go along of course none of the
practice matters if the TV cameras miss
the money shot I just hope that they've
got their timings right and it happens
when it's supposed to happen and that's
where veteran football director Mike
Arnold comes in thank God it's a
military plane they're normally on time
and they're normally spot-on Arnold has
directed hundreds of football games for
CBS Sports Sunday he'll direct his fifth
Super Bowl I mean that flyover happens
in about two seconds so you better be on
it because they're not gonna circle
around the stadium and do it again for
you is that more stressful for you Mike
than actually doing the game yeah I've
got a lot of experience covering
football games I've got less experience
cover and flyovers so it is a little
more stressful believe it or not adding
to the uncertainty the weather which
will dictate whether the stadium will
have its iconic roof open or shut and if
the flyover can be captured from inside
the stadium as the fans will see it I
think I gotta just be flexible so I've
got to be prepared with an outside shot
I've got to be prepared with a shot
inside from the field and we'll see what
the weather's like that day and what
decision they make plus or minus two or
three seconds it's a lot to coordinate
all the ball requiring each person to
focus on his or her role so we'll have
me as Thunderbird 7 in the control room
will have Thunderbird number 8 up on top
of the stadium with the radio talking to
the pilots and so I'll be there with the
computer a little spreadsheet hacking
the clock at the end of each line of the
national anthem to make sure we're on
time on time for when Gladys Knight
sings those famous last words of the
national anthem
[Music]
it's land of the free home of the brave
so when those words come I'm probably
gonna be looking up to the sky look
looking for those planes it's all down
to the timing the director is worried
about the timing he's reliant on you
who are you reliant on I'm reliant on
Gladys Knight to execute on script on
time hopefully we can sit down have
lunch maybe I can talk to her about how
important that is I'd say I'm gonna do
it and you guys have know exactly when
I'm gonna do this line right here and I
believe in Gladys Knight she was very
firm that she will get the timing down
as for the roof the NFL tells us that
will be a game day decision whether it
is open or closed and nor they actually
can decide as late as 90 minutes before
whether or not they want to keep it open
and I'm sorry that you're jealous of me
it was just the coolest trip up there I
can't lie oh my gosh I've done it before
I've flown and I can tell you it's the
most thrilling experience so so did you
do any tricks with the Thunderbirds any
fun maneuvers yeah yeah after we did the
fly over the stadium they actually took
me out to another space and we tried the
g-forces so they can get up to 9 G's I
made it to 7 G's and at that point when
he said do you want to try some more
while my head may have wanted to my
stomach did not so I decided that that
was enough for me we also did a couple
barrel rolls I was able to be like on
the side flying look I can't even
explain the whole thing it is just
absolutely amazing to me that these are
men and women that do this in like a
theater of war under so much pressure
and you know what your body goes through
and doing that so for me it's the ride
of a lifetime but it really is when you
you know when you get down to the basics
this is something that is so important
to the Air Force or the Navy fliers as
well they do an incredible job it was
cool it was just cool I'm assuming you
waited to eat until you were off the
plane
no so this was this surprising thing you
actually are supposed to have a meal
beforehand and then I got over it with a
burger and fries after there you go yeah
that's a good day we will be watching
Dana thank you